and now it's time for bomb reviews with
Chester a bomb tonight's review
Maleficent
oh my god this is a greatest movie I've
ever seen in my life I nose boilers
here's this girl call me efficient and
she looks like Tweety Bird if he was
swallowed and out by Pan's
Labyrinth she comes across as Scottish
boy I was at Scottish boy once until I
abused the responsibilities of the kilt
so they grow up together for years and
years and fall in love until one day he
decides that he's even elements in his
life but we fell in love and we got
along so well together yeah I know I'm
just even perhaps we can compromise on
our kingdoms can come together nope no
just evil you know politically this
makes no sense My Kingdom has a ton of
treasures and we just a format really to
the Vil
now give me your wings why so I can
convince the king that I killed you so I
can be king but again can we talk about
a way to maybe trick the king and we can
work something out read this oh how
poison II so the Scottish guy is now
King and that really pisses Maleficent
author she decides she needs a new set
of wings the finishing tresses crow into
a human oh why did you turn me into a
human I need someone else to be my wings
but don't you rule all of the fairies
now yes and don't they have Wayne's
looking young man have a shirt open for
the ladies oh the Twilight a face so
years go by and the Scottish King his
birth to a daughter not him literally
though his voice is high pitch enough I
can see the confusion and Maleficent is
like at age 16 the child should die by
pricking her finger on a spinning wheel
why is spinning wheel a spinning wheel
kill my parents and it is a Disney film
anyone who's a parent will be dead in a
second but let me out so the king is
like you three fairies must take my
daughter away and hide her for 16 years
wait could she just stay with you and
then we hide her 16 years later
no no it's safer this way but she also
said true love's kiss will wake her up
so maybe we just have her fall in love
with somebody over those 16 you all are
crazy this is the most sensible pad no
keep doing you three fairies who I've
never taken care of a baby before and
don't even know how to feed them right
babies bounce don't they so the fairies
take the baby to a cottage where
Maleficent finds them right away please
this is gonna be a short movie
Maleficent ends up raising her more than
the fairies do which is kind of
counterproductive it's kind of like
Ronald McDonald befriending a cow who's
gonna be in a happy meal in a minute so
sixteen years pass and the baby grows up
into
fanning girls been that creepy one sort
of and she thinks Maleficent is her
fairy godmother wrong movie honey that
one they're going to destroy in March my
maleficent life the girl so much that
she decides to take away the curse I
take away the curse but it turns out
it's irreversible oh no forgot to read
the fine magic print door or pricks her
finger and falls asleep
MoMA Levinson brings a voice she fell in
love like the other day and the boy is
kissing you're really going to wake her
up or we get a ripoff frozen and have a
woman's love do it Amy that many making
film that's making us millions and
millions of data is even not you answer
my question so Maleficent kisses her on
the head and awaits her up but Sarah Lee
they forgot the kingís tan even so he
surrounds her with iron is that the only
thing I can burn a ferry which knowing
that this war should have been over in
two seconds Thunder roaring guess what
limpets and her wings back which kind of
makes you wonder why she didn't do that
before she's been the castle like two or
three times and she kind of sort of
kills the king am i trying to sort of
kill you I don't know I'm kind of sort
of killing myself
well then I guess this kind of sword as
morally sound tiger sorta yeah so
Maleficent is now good again or our
rules our kingdom or the other people's
Kingdom or both they don't really
clarify but she gets to wear a pretty
crown and then we'll be reminds us that
the prince was in the movie I'm in the
movie the end donkey the movie me like
no sense whatsoever I like it so much
cuz I had fairies and frogs and all
sorts of weird looking creatures that's
what I see every day isn't that way cool
or racist
this is jittery boom scene change
ah come on siowiy yeah come on judge
come on I promise good lord will say
anything more racist alarm did you just
say the q''-word